Mana Onsgaard's home looks a bit like an antiques
store.
He can't sell everything he salvages from
the river straight away.
It's best to collect as much as possible before
looking for a buyer.
In recent weeks he's collected amulets, coins
and glass beads.
Mana comes home with a haul pretty much every
single day - but it doesn't always include
anything of real value.
"If I find something underwater that I think
could be gold, I bite on it.
Most metals have a bitter taste, but gold
doesn't taste of anything.
It's also heavy and smooth.
A gold breastplate is the most valuable thing
I ever found.
It was seven years ago, after the 2011 floods.
I got 1300 euros for it.
I sold this ring for 800 euros.
That was a while ago."
The buyers are antiques dealers.
Mana doesn't want to name them.
He knows the whole trade in sunken treasure
is a legal grey area.
"Of course all these things belonged to someone,
before they ended up in the water.
But as long as they aren't national relics,
you can keep them.
I have had some encounters with the authorities.
But one man's trash is another man's treasure."+++
Mana lives in a house on stilts directly on
the river.
The settlement is called Mittakam and was
built around 100 years ago.
Mana's grandfather was one of the first inhabitants.
Today the floating village of Mittakam is
home to about 120 people.
Most of the men are treasure divers like Mana.
Mana's 11-year-old daughter goes to school
and his wife Yui works as a chambermaid in
a hotel.
She used to go out with him when he went diving
- but only as a lookout.
Traditionally, women don't dive themselves.
"It isn't women's work.
Unless you're especially brave.
The thought of being unerwater scares me.
You don't know what's there - shards of glass,
nails...My husband is an experienced diver.
But I still worry everytime he goes diving."
Mana learnt to dive from his father.
It's the only skill he has.
His homemade diving helmet is his most important
piece of equipment.
It weighs over 20 kilos.
While Prayad lays anchor, Mana gets ready
for his first dive.
That involves the traditional "Wai Khru" ceremony.
Mana pays his respects to his ancestors and
asks them to protect him.
His partner puts the heavy helmet on his head...and
then he's off.
The weight of it pushes him straight under.
There's zero visibility underwater.
Mana finally comes back up.
He shows us a handful of coins that he's found.
Mana's also brought up some sludge from the
riverbed, which they'll sift through in search
of other valuables.
Today's findings include a piece of fishing
sinker and a few more coins from the 19th
century.
"I'm happy enough.
Coins like these aren't all that special,
I find quite a few of them.
You can get one or two hundred Baht for them.
Obviously gold is much more valuable.
But gold isn't something you find every day."+++
9:12
Mana and Prayad spent about 6 hours on the
water today, taking it in turns to go diving.
By the end of the day, they've recovered some
two dozen old coins.
They'll make about 25 euros - over three times
more than what they would have earnt in a
minimum wage job.
Mana hopes he'll be able to continue making
a living as a treasure diver.
The river is a gift that keeps on giving.